[Music]
hello again and welcome to another
episode of whatsa Prof Walter we are
back in outet yes
thankfully that was a little bit too
modern for us yes that's a little bit
too
funky well you put together something
that
all
ages should know and has been coming for
Millennia yes I believe Martin this is
the most important subject in the
universe and it will be the curriculum
of the
ages and it is the most controversial
subject and I believe every conflict
that has arisen in this world is
centered in this
curriculum and as we near the close of
time this conflict will
escalate and multitudes multitudes in
the valley of decision sure so Mar if we
look at our
backdrop then you will see the
multitudes multitudes in the valley of
decision at the bottom
you have a central
cross it's slightly blurred for a
reason and you have two
thieves one on the right hand and one on
the left
hand and if you look up into the sky
there you'll see there on the left which
is Jesus's right there is a light in
that cloud and it's sort of shining down
on the right side of Jesus and on the
the head of the penitent Thief yeah and
the other side is darkness and clouds
and
lightning and
thunder so this is the decision that
everybody has to
make
why why was this
necessary for an example yes was there
no other way no and why are there only
two
thieves on either side now both of them
have no righteousness no that represents
Humanity we have no righteousness of our
own all have sinned and fall short of
the glor glory of God there are none
righteous no not one
exactly so here are two now the the
thief on Jesus's right which is here on
our
left did he have time
to display good works
no so what saved him the grace of Jesus
and his righteousness a look of a look
of Faith right so he had zero
righteousness of his own no so he can
make no claim yeah other than relying on
the imputed righteousness of Christ
he had no time for sanctification no so
here we have the example of
justification that's it and
sanctification by promise exactly the
sanctification actually also happened at
it at the same time and he if he would
have come down had would have to stay in
the sanctification he would have to stay
in that process but here with no Merit
of his own he is saved by the
righteousness of Christ righteousness by
faith is the center of the
Gospel now Martin this
picture is the study of
Eternity we will never fathom it in its
fullness no so we lay no claim to
Superior knowledge we are just saying
that this decision is a decision that
everybody has to make there are two
crosses yes on either side there are
only two classes that's it one that
accepts it and the other class that
rejects it that's it there can be
thousands of sub classes but there are
really only two yeah but before we get
into this Martin this is such an
important subject will you pray for us
I'll
pray our heavenly father thank you that
we can study this wonderful gesture this
curriculum of the ages but we cannot do
it without the enlightenment of the holy
spirit because then we will go off on
our own understanding so help us to
understand this as you intended it to be
in Jesus name amen
amen now Martin here's another
example which illustrates the decision
of
humanity these are the sacrifices that
Cain and Abel brought and in the
foreground there you have
Abel and he is sacrificing the
sacrificial
lamb and in the background there you
have Cain who brought the works of his
own
hands he refused to follow the
dictates he said my works are sufficient
for you
yeah so here are the two
classes Abel
represents accepting the sacrifice the
atoning sacrifice of the Lamb of God
that taketh away the sins of the world
and Cain who said my Works should be
sufficient to gain entry into the
kingdom yeah two classes two classes and
no matter how many subcategories you
have amongst them there are only two
classes yeah you either accept the
sacrifice
and receive the
righteousness of Christ as a gift or you
try achieving it through your own works
that's true only two options it seems to
represent also at the end of time when
the mark of the beast will be enforced
some will acknowledge the they don't
want to go ahead with it by keep keep
God's Commandments in their forehead and
on the hand so that's making a decision
like Abel did and acting upon it yes but
those who receive the mark are receiving
a spous Doctrine that's it so I would
say let's compare it to those who
receive it on the forehead and on the
hand with the Seal of God that's it so
so again you have two ceilings the one
of God's people being sealed and the
other one the sealing of God's opponents
that's
it now another interesting point in
history is that those who follow the
dictates of God like Abel over here and
bring the sacrificial
lamb and accept the gift of
Salvation and the righteousness of
Christ they will feel the enmity of the
cans of this world yeah and the fact of
the matter is that this is a declaration
of war yeah because
Cain will slay
Abel and this has been the war and the
controversy from the beginning two ways
of Salvation yeah yes that's the only
two it's either by works or by the
righteousness of Christ and Martin we're
going to speak frankly about some
issues this is not in intended to attack
anyone but truth is truth and truth
cannot be compromised no and therefore
truth has to be stated in Clarity so
that people can make a
decision it will
infuriate the canes of this world and
they will grab the stone to crush your
head and they will attack you but that
is no reason why we should hide our
light under a bushel amen
yeah you know Mar there are those within
our ranks mhm who believe that for the
sake of an ecumenical climate yeah we
should rather be quiet when it comes to
attacking spous religious systems for
the sake of of acceptance for the sake
of acceptance but Martin Jesus said I
have not come to bring peace no but a
sword oh for sure and the sword will
have to cleave and the sword is the word
of God so let the word of God do the
talking amen so we don't go and water
down our Doctrine or compromise to get
our names on a list no and this is not
to attack anyone no this is to create an
option so that people can make choices
informed
choices so let's look at some of the
religious beliefs out there here is an
article from Catholic straight
answers about the good thief and the bad
thief now we must remember that
Catholicism bases a lot of its doctrines
on tradition yes and tradition is the
Contex text in which everything
including the Bible must be studied and
read right true and Jesus said that you
have made void God's word through the
Traditions so those who believe that we
must take God at his word cannot mingle
tradition and the word yeah so let's
read what Catholic straight answers has
to say about the good thief and the bad
thief in Tradition the good thief has
named St
gmas and the bad thief guest us note
that sister an Catherine emmerich in her
visions of the passion recorded the name
of the bad thief as
gmas which was also used in the movie
The
Passion so the movie The Passion was
based on Catholic Visionaries wasn't
based on the word of God and that's very
important that we understand extremely
important to realize another story that
circulated in early church but has no
substantiation relates how the Holy
Family encountered these two thieves on
their journey to Egypt when fleeing the
wroth of King Herod moved with
compassion dismas wanted to leave the
holy family
unharmed but gestas wanted to Rob and
hurt them
so this must bribe guest us this is now
according to tradition of course with 40
dras to leave them in peace the blessed
mother said to dmas the Lord God shall
sustain you with his right hand and give
you remission of
sins so who who is promising the
remission of sins here Mary
Mary thereupon the Infant Jesus added
after 30 years mother the Jews will
crucify me in Jerusalem and these two
robbers will be lifted on the cross with
me dismas on my right hand guest us on
my left and after that day dismas shall
go before me into
Paradise now there's no substantiation
they say but Catholicism loves these
apocryphal writings y so
Martin this story is a fantasy yeah
it's it's actually pathetic that people
could put any Credence into something
like this the problem is if you really
study the Bible and that subject and if
you really read the spirit of Prophecy
The Desire of Ages then you can see this
doesn't fit in with Jesus's Style no it
doesn't and in any case the Infant Jesus
who was still on breast milk wouldn't be
able to make these statements and Mary
forget it completely because she was
just as surprised at the cruci
crucifixion of Jesus as the disciples
were so this is obviously a concoction
mhm but the seed that is planted is that
the good thief stands under the
protection of Mary that's what it says
let's just briefly go back to The
Passion of the Christ Mel Gibson told
Christianity
today I've been actually amazed at the
way I would say the Evangelical audience
has hands down responded to this film
more than any other Christian group what
makes it so amazing he says is that the
film is so Marian Gibson calls her a
tremendous co-redemptrix and mediatrix
what do you say to that Martin no I say
that's blasphemous that's blasphemous
right because there's one mediator
between God and man and that's Christ
Jes the man Christ Jesus this is not
biblical no and it's actually
also to me it's also amazing that people
don't the Evangelical Christians don't
even realize how Maran this is yes
exactly but it goes further and deeper
than
that this is a a picture from the movie
of the penitent thief and you will
notice that he's wearing something
around his neck does the Bible say
anything about that no nothing right
nothing so let's look at this in The
Passion of the Christ the penitent thief
on the cross was wearing a Catholic
Brown
scapula thus enabling him to bypass
Purgatory okay now m is Purgatory a
Biblical Doctrine not at all all right
is this where the Reformation started
with Martin Luther that's it for
indulgences to get out of purgatory all
right now what was the purpose of
purgatory to pay for your sins to pay
for the sins that you have been forgiven
by priest yeah so so who pays for the
sins the the person himself all right so
do you then need Christ to pay them for
you yeah no so this is a negation of the
atonement okay you can use of his Merit
but that's it yes the procession
fulfilled exactly the Catholic Stations
of the Cross and the five s sorrowful
mysteries of the Rosary there's none of
this in the Bible no none of it so this
is back to tradition all right and
according to them
Martin Jesus on the cross said it is
accomplished oh rather than it is
finished now why would they do that we
have to study these things out according
to Rome it was the Eucharist which was
accomplished at the
cross now the Eucharist is a
continuation of the sacrifice yeah in
fact they say it is the exact same
sacrifice as took place on the cross but
the Bible says he was sacrificed once
for all for
all so the Eucharist sacrament of our
Salvation accomplished by Christ on the
cross is also a sacrifice of praise in
Thanksgiving for the work of creation
this comes from the catechism of the
Catholic Church article
1359 we must look at that in a little
bit more more
detail so here is article 1359 the
Eucharist the sacrament of our Salvation
accomplished by Christ on the cross is
also a sacrifice of praise and
thanksgiving for the work of Creation in
the Eucharistic sacrifice the whole of
creation loved by God is presented to
the father through the death and
resurrection of Christ
through Christ the
church can offer the sacrifice of praise
in Thanksgiving for all that God has
made good beautiful and just in creation
and in
humanity so here it states that the
cross is an
accomplishment let's say an initiation
if you want of a Perpetual sacrifice in
the mass put it in motion
and this sacrifice is offered on behalf
of the people yeah but through this they
are made beautiful and good the church
the church makes the people good and
beautiful through this Eucharistic
sacrifice now Martin is that biblical no
not at all no it is Christ's
righteousness that is imputed to you mhm
that is your
righteousness no ritual no attendance of
any ritual such of the mass can
contribute to that
sacrifice so this is a very important
point you see Martin there are two
classes as we have said those that
accept the sacrifice and those that
don't correct those that accept the free
gift of Salvation and the imputed
righteousness of Christ and those that
bring their works yeah here you have a
clear case of bringing a works because
Jesus didn't finish it yeah because it
was he just accomplished the mass yeah
so put it in motion and now you have to
continue doing it through the
church so if we read the DU Rhymes which
is the Jesuit version of the Bible Jesus
therefore when he had taken the vinegar
said it is consumated
it's a very strange
translation and bowing his head he gave
up the
ghost now when you read it in the Bible
and not in the Catholic version it says
when Jesus therefore had received the
vinegar he said it is
finished and he bowed his head and gave
up The Ghost and if you look it up in
the
concordances then the word is Tello and
it means to bring to a close to finish
to end past finish to perform execute
complete
fulfill so that the thing done
corresponds to what has been said the
order of command Etc with special
reference to the subject matter to carry
out the contents of a command to
complete the process it's a completed
protest to to accomplish so it's not
consumated so Martin let's just go back
to the Bible because that is the only
Safe Way Isaiah
53:12 therefore will I divide him a
portion with the great and he shall
divide the spoil with the strong because
he has poured out his soul unto death
and he was numbered with the
transgressors and he bear the sin of
many and made intercession for the
transgressors that's the Bible yeah yeah
and that is the Old Testament now Martin
he bore the sins mhm so there's no
Purgatory there where you bear the
consequences of your sins and he is the
one who makes intercession for the
transgressor not Mary or anyone else or
the church it is Jesus that does it Mark
15:28 and the scripture was fulfilled
which says and he was numbered with the
transgressors so the New Testament
applies this Old Testament Isaiah
portion to Jesus Christ yes and to the
Cross so it is cast in stone that's it
you cannot move
it now let's get to another little word
that creates controversy the word
atonement now this word was coined by
Tindle yeah he was mulling over the
meaning of the words and it's actually a
beautiful word because it means at
onement
together Romans
51 and not only so but we also joy in
God through our Lord Jesus Christ by
whom we have now received the
atonement made one again with God that's
it so if we go to the New World
Encyclopedia atonement means that two
parties estranged from each other
because one of them offends the other
eventually reconcil to each other it
usually contains two stages the
Offenders Act of expiation for
forgiveness from the offended party and
then reconciliation which is regained
state of unity
thereafter so this is what it means this
is a description of the word yeah
atonement now even the Catholic Bibles
use this word and the modern versions
use this word but but they have another
definition for it so you have to be very
careful how you read something yeah
because if you don't have their
definition you might be caught of God
because it is the same word that's very
very sneaky it's very sneaky very sneaky
indeed and another word that's very
important is the word propitiation
M Romans 3:25 whom God has set forth to
be a
propitiation comes from the Greek
hilasterion through faith in his blood
this is very very important to declare
his righteousness for the remission of
sins that are passed through the
forbearance of God to declare I say at
this time his righteousness that he
might be just and the the justifier of
him which believeth in
Jesus where is boasting then it is
excluded by what law of Works nay but by
the law of Faith so mtin according to
this text how are you saved only by the
blood of Christ through faith all right
is the blood important you not you
cannot be saved without it well without
the shedding of blood there's no
forgiveness of sins doesn't the Bible
say so exactly so the blood is
absolutely essential
and this propitiation this word
hilasterion has another meaning as well
the Ark of the Covenant had a mercy seat
on
it and that is the hoston okay yeah so
the hilasterion the mercy seed Shields
you from the condemnation of the law
that's it and it is the Throne of God
that's it it is the
epicenter of his power and Grace that
see represents Christ and if you don't
appropriate him over you then you stand
under the condation of the
law so let's look at this word it's a
beautiful word propitiation means the
Turning Away of
Roth by an offering in relation to
soteriology which is the science of
Salvation propitiation means plating or
satisfying the wrath of God
by the atoning sacrifice of Christ this
comes from ry's basic theology a popular
systematic guide to understanding the
Biblical
truths and if we look it up in the
concordance propitiation
hoston NE of a derivative of this one
over here and expat placing or place or
thing that is concretely an atoning
vicory victim or specifically the lid of
the Ark in the temple The Mercy Seat
propitiation there's a lot of theology
in that word yeah no it's amazing it is
an amazing amazing study the Turning
Away of
Wrath people say then God is a wrathful
God yeah yeah he hates everyone he wants
to punish
everyone but they have a demiss he hates
sin that's it but he loves The Sinner
he's got a wrath against sin ah and sin
is the transgression of the law by
definition so we need to understand the
curriculum of the ages we need to
understand the Plan of
Salvation And if we don't understand it
then we fall into the category of
Cain unfortunately like you said there's
only two there's only two so we need to
make this very very
plain all right so in contrast the
principle that man is able to save
himself through his own efforts lies at
the basis of every non-Christian
religion only two choices Martin that's
it you're either able or you're can
you're either the thief on the right or
the thief on the left there's no other
way that's it so let's have a look at
this war
salvation in Islam now I could
give hundreds of verses and hundreds of
sayings but let's stick to it very
simply this comes from an Islamic Source
since God is all Mighty he doesn't need
the charade concocted by Christians in
order to forgive
man in the Quran God says we are all
created in a state of goodness now stop
there is that the opposite of the Bible
yes all have sinned and fall short of
the glory there's not one righteous no
not one The Heart Is exceedingly Wicked
that's it above all things Martin this
is the exact opposite of the scriptures
right this Falls right in with
Hollywood follow your heart follow your
heart how can you follow your heart if
your heart is exceedingly Wicked
know so M he has not burdened man with
an original sin having forgiven Adam and
Eve now the doctrine of original sin is
a Catholic Doctrine you inherit the sin
of Adam nowhere in the Bible does it say
you inherit the sin of Adam you inherit
his Fallen nature yeah because when he
fell he had a fallen nature and all he
could pass on to his posterity was a
fallen nature because he didn't have
another one yeah so the bad luck for you
is that you have a fallen nature that's
it and your wife has never noticed
it no I'm sure she has oh I see all
right according to the Quran Allah
forgives
us as we are all personally responsible
for our
actions there is no need for humanly
conco savior in Islam salvation comes
from God
Alone there's no sacrifice
needed Allah forgives you and through
your good works and your goodness that
you have yeah you can attain Heaven that
is the way of Cain exactly right that is
denying the
sacrifice denying the Lamb of God
precisely so denying the
they will offer their works and not the
Lamb on the all right now that's a major
religion that's more than a billion
people on this planet yeah
okay what about the Buddhist World well
here comes the New World Encyclopedia
Buddhism is far from theistic so it has
no real concept of atonement with God it
rather focuses on atonement with fellow
humans teaching the importance of
forgiveness even if you are offended by
someone who commits sin against you you
are supposed to forgive him so atonement
is initiated more by the offended party
than by the
offender you are supposed to practice
meta loving kindness karuna compassion
and mudita sympathetic Joy but the whole
idea of forgiveness comes from the
belief that it prevents both the
offended and the offender from Dev liing
negative and harmful emotions from the
karma that unfortunately binds them in
sin and
misery no need for a savior no you
perform your own
actions so you do the Forgiveness yes
and that's your good works that's it and
that's what you need so no savior needed
in Buddhism but there goes another great
portion of
humanity the same for Hinduism mhm there
is no mediator
necessary all right let's have a look at
the Catholic
view Alan Jones the Reverend of Grace
Cathedral in San Francisco wrote a book
calling called reimagining
Christianity in this book he States the
church's fixation on the death of Jesus
as the universal saving act must
end and the place of the Cross must be
reimagined in Christian Faith why
because of the cult of suffering and the
vindictive God behind
it so they
deny that Jesus died for your
sins God would not make his son suffer
Jesus died yes because he followed
through his good works even unto death
but not for you it's not the blood of
the Lamb that saves you it's your good
works yeah yeah and I was thinking we
also had that Jesus seminar they stated
that you must love the son but hate the
father Yes it comes to almost the same
exactly the same thing but uh God in
Christ was reconciling the world to
himself the issue is sin not the person
no all right of the atonement Joan
says Jesus's sacrifice was to appease an
Angry
God Penal substitution was the name of
this vile Doctrine so it totally denies
the atonement and calls it a vile
Doctrine but the Bible says without the
shedding of blood there's no forgiveness
of sins yeah so M we have two classes of
people that's
it distinctly and whether you're now a
Buddhist or whether you're a Islam or
whether you're a shamanist or whether
you're a Hindu all of the religion or
whether you're a Catholic you don't need
the atonement according to them you need
the church you need the
works and you will pay for your own sins
in
purgatory no need for a
savior now let's see what uh the spirit
of Prophecy has to say manuscripts
released
548 God so loved the world that he gave
his only begotten son that whosoever
believeth in him should not perish
but have everlasting
life these words show us why God's wroth
descended on his only begotten son while
the innocent suffered for the guilty
while the just bore the punishment holy
due to the
unjust Jesus came to bear the penalty of
man's transgression to uphold and
vindicate the immutability of the law of
God and the rectitude of his government
he came to make an end of sin and to
bring in Everlasting
righteousness is that in harmony with
scripture mod 100% it's actually a very
good beautiful explanation of what we
find in all right so we have an
introduction here that the Evangelical
World leaves up mhm namely the law of
God yeah because sin is the
transgression of the law and God hates
sin so if God hates sin then he hates
the transgression of the law that's it
and by
Jesus dying on the cross he actually
established the law yes the validity of
the law far from taking it away he
established it because if you could have
taken it away he wouldn't have had to
die because where there is no law
there's no transgression that's
it so Martin let's just make
sure and the only way to make sure is to
go back to the scriptures that's it
Colossians 1:14 in whom we have
Redemption through his blood even the
Forgiveness of sins is the blood
important it's the Central Point
Colossians 1:20 and having made peace
through the blood of the
Cross by him to reconcile all things
unto himself by him I say whether they
be things in Earth or things in heaven
is there any other way no it's the Lamb
of God or nothing right and the faith
through in that blood in the blood all
right verse 21 and you that were
sometime alienated and enemies in your
mind by Wicked Works yet now has he
reconciled do you recognize the thief on
the cross the penitent Thief 100% did he
have to wear a scapula to be under the
protection of Mary no because he's not
going to Purgatory to go and pay off the
Forgiveness of his sins they've already
been paid and it's also shown here that
Wicked
works all our works is filthy rags yes
now the Catholics say he didn't go to
Purgatory because he bypassed it as a
result of of Mary no but they don't get
rid of purgatory because you still have
to go
to all right let's carry on verse
22 in the body of his flesh through
death to present you holy and
unblameable
and
unreprovable in his sight how are you
saved Martin through the blood through
the blood who presents you unblamable
and unreprovable your works or him
Christ Christ Hebrews 9:22 and almost
all things are by the law purged with
blood and without shedding of blood is
no
remission is Islam right no is
Catholicism right no is Buddhism right
no is any other religion out there other
than biblical Christianity right no no
can't be now this is not an attack is it
us saying this no no it's the scriptures
say the is saying this you're right
Martin you're absolutely right all right
review and
Herald The Plan of Salvation was laid in
a
sacrifice so Broad and deep and high
that it is
immeasurable Christ is did not send his
angels to this Fallen World while he
remained in heaven but he himself went
without the camp bearing the reproach he
became a Man of Sorrows and acquainted
with grief himself took our infirmities
and bore our weaknesses and the absence
of self-denial in his professed
followers God regards as a denial of the
Christian name those who profess to be
one with Christ and indulge their self
desires for Rich and expensive clothing
furniture and food are Christians only
in name to be Christian is to be
Christlike
Martin does this add an an extra little
Dimension true yeah if you have accepted
the righteousness of
Christ then who dwells in you Christ
Christ can you then still do what you
did before no you have to become a new
creature all right so are you telling me
that if you accept Jesus Christ and
accept his righteousness which is right
doing then you must be and walk like he
did yeah so are you trying to tell me
that the righteousness of Christ will be
made manifest by obedience to his
requirements it has to be otherwise
you're in ajed position it can't mean
those all right so can you say as a
Christian well I'm saved by the blood of
the lamb now I can enjoy my life eat
drink and be merry carry on as before
because I'm covered by the blood of the
Lamb unfortunately the exact opposite
it's the exact opposite right you have
to become Christlike that's not what you
can do all right so why did Jesus have
to die
and why can you not deny the atonement
without jeopardizing your eternal
life the issue was Justice and
mercy the law of God is Central to this
because Justice is a Judicial word and
you cannot have a Judicial word without
law yeah that's true is that right yeah
that's true if you go to a court of law
law you are judged by the
law and the one who represents you is a
laer a lawyer yeah right and you've got
a judge yes that's judging it right so
Justice now the wages of sin is death
all right let's rephrase this the wages
of transgression of the law mhm is death
death and if you are a transgressor then
Justice demands that you die yeah that's
what the law says all right what is Mery
de demand Mercy takes away the penalty
of the law ah so the condemnation is
gone yeah so M would you say that
Justice and mercy are two
opposites yes they're absolutely
opposite right yes Justice demands death
Mercy requires life that's it they are
absolutely
opposite and so if you want to say but
transgressors deserve justice
mhm then that must exclude Mercy that's
it because then the penalty has to be
enforced right now I assume that Satan
when he was thrown out of Heaven which
was
Justice said to God EX excuse
me how can
you give Mercy to humanity when they
transgress when you are a God of
Justice if they transgressed they
deserve the same penalty death that's it
but you are saying that you are a
merciful god and that you will forgive
them then you're not a just
God well if you take it on that he's
right all right now what if I tell you m
that Justice and mercy kissed each other
at the cross
yes so the cross in some way must
satisfy the demands of Justice exactly
and enable in some way the demands of
Mercy yeah is that correct that must be
correct all right so the cross is
pivotal and a denial of any of these
components is a denial of the atonement
yeah all right let's look at it Psalms
89:14 Justice and judgment are the
habitation of thy
Throne mercy and Truth Shall go before
thy face two
opposites they cannot be reconciled says
the devil that's a thing all right and
they cannot be
reconciled says the religious world too
yeah so you must satisfy the demands of
Justice through your good works that's
right you must atone for your sins
through your good
works Isaiah 9:7 of the increase of his
government and
peace there shall be no end upon the
throne of David and upon the kingdom to
order it and to establish it with
judgment and with Justice from
henceforth even
forever the Zeal of the Lord of hosts
will per per form this so if you take
this word peace and you look up Psalms
119: 165 it says great peace have they
which love thy law and nothing shall
offend them so Martin can we read of the
increase of the government and those
that love the law there shall be no end
upon the true yeah judgment and Justice
will take place that's
it all right but then you have Psalms 85
which says mercy and Truth are met
together righteousness and peace have
kissed each other now truth Martin let's
redefine that Psalms 119 verse 142 thy
righteousness is an everlasting
righteousness thy law is truth that's it
so Martin can if we rephrase it mercy
and law are met together would that be
permissible yes because it stands there
there's a definition of truth right mhm
all right well so there again you have
Justice and mercy that's it and even on
the righteousness and peace where we use
the peace for the the law you can say
righteousness and the law have kissed
each other all right so there they've
kissed each other where did they kiss
each other at the cross the only place
where they can kiss each
other here's a quote from the Desire of
Ages
Satan with his Fierce Temptations rang
the Heart of Jesus the Savior could not
see through the portals of the
Tomb sure why not because Martin sin is
exceedingly sinful sin is the
transgression of the law and he died for
the transgressions of the law now the
wages of sin is death yeah so he could
not see through the portals of the Tomb
so what death did he die the first death
or the second death the second death yes
because there is no after correct hope
did not present to him his coming forth
from the grave of conqueror or tell him
of the father's acceptance of his
sacrifice so to him it was the ultimate
sacrifice he feared that sin was so
offensive to God that their separation
was to be eternal
and that makes it so much more clear
that it's the second death yes there's
no hope and it's Eternal yes Christ felt
the anguish which The Sinner will feel
when mercy shall no longer plead for the
guilty race it was the sense of sin
bringing the father's wroth upon him as
man's substitute that made the cup he
drank so bitter and broke the heart of
the Son of God this is amazing statement
Martin
let's mull it over a little bit the
wages of sin is yeah death
death did Jesus have any sin in him no
Martin if if Jesus had just the tiniest
little sin in him would he have risen
from the dead no it would have been
Eternal right that's it but the Bible
says death could not hold him yeah so
why because he had no sin MH so there
was he was dying but there was no
transgression
that it needed that he had right now it
gets very complicated so who did he die
for then yeah for Humanity all right
we'll have to unpack this because the
Plan of Salvation was laid very
deep very deep
indeed so these are my thoughts Martin
oh the
price all the pain and guilt of humanity
he
bore and what an insult to the Son of
God to the deny the atonement would you
age with that yes for sure I mean that
defies the whole reason why Jesus came
to this earth I will continue to say
what an insult that Protestants should
sign the joint Declaration on
justification when he paid it all and to
him we hold it we owe it
everything 2 Corinthians 5:21 for he has
made him to be sin for us who knew no
sin that we might be made the righteous
n of God in him so the answer lies he
became sin for
us that's a complicated thought we have
to unpack that Hebrews 9:14 how much
more shall the blood of Christ who
through the eternal spirit offered
himself without spot to God Purge your
conscience from dead Works to receive
the Living God whose work is the work of
salvation God Jesus yes or verse 28 so
Christ was once offered to Bear the sins
of many so did he consumate the mass
which is a continuation of the of the
sacrifice no no no no he finished and
unto them that look for him shall he
appear the second time without sin unto
salvation that's the Plan of Salvation
yeah now we have to look at the real ity
of
it so let's
reiterate there are only two classes in
the world today and only two classes
will be recognized in the
Judgment those who violate God's law and
those who obey it Christ gives the test
by which to prove our loyalty or
disloyalty if you love me he says keep
my Commandments he that has my
Commandments and keepeth them he is that
loveth me and he that loveth me shall be
loved of my father and I will love him
and I will manifest myself to him that's
a promise
right he that loveth me not keepeth not
my sayings and the word which you hear
is not mine but the father's which sent
me if you keep my Commandments you shall
abide in my love even as I have kept my
father's Commandments and abide in his
love is that plain that is so clear is
it biblical yes because it comes right
out of the Bible it's like reading the
scriptures you can't deny it it comes
from Christ objects lessons all right so
is the law pivotal yes
okay let's continue in consequence of
Adam's sin death passed upon the whole
human race all alike go down to the
grave and through the provisions of the
Plan of Salvation all are to be brought
forth from their
graves there shall be a resurrection of
the Dead both of the just and the unjust
according to acts
24:15 for as in Adam all die even so in
Christ shall all be made alive 1
Corinthians
15:22 but a distinction is made between
two
classes that are brought forth all that
are in the grave shall hear his voice
and shall come forth they that have done
good unto the resurrection of life and
they that have done evil unto the
resurrection of damnation quoting John
528 and
29 they who have been accounted worthy
of the resurrection of Life blessed and
holy on such the second death has no
power but those who have not through
repentance and Faith secured pardon must
receive the penalty of transgression the
wages of sin which is death right that's
it they suffer punishment varying in
duration and intensity according to
their works but finally ending in the
second death since it is impossible for
God
consistently with his Justice and mercy
to save The Sinner any s he deprives him
of his existence which he which his
transgressions have forfeited and of
which he had proved himself unworthy
says an inspired writer yet a little
while and the wicked shall not be yay
Thou shalt diligently consider his place
and it shall not be and another declares
they shall be as though they had not
been quoting Psalms 37:10 and abah 16
covered with infamy they sink into
hopeless Eternal Oblivion is it biblical
biblical and it's if you still doubt if
there's more ways that you can choose
there's this also shows you there's only
two which Resurrection would you want to
be part of Martin the first the first
resurrection because the second death
has no power over you all right M this
is the reality of the
matter Deuteronomy
24:6 introduces another very important
point which complicates
issues it says in Deuteronomy 24:16 the
fathers shall not be put to death for
the children neither shall the children
be put to death for the fathers every
man shall be put to death for his own
sin according to this verse Martin can I
pay for your sins
no can my father pay for my sins
no all right that raises the question
how can Jesus die for my
sins because he's God and all
humanity is derived from him all right
let's let's look at this in some detail
because it's a very important point
right numbers 14:8 the Lord is
longsuffering and of great Mercy
forgiving iniquity and transgression and
by no means clearing the guilty
so they have Justice and mercy right
visiting the iniquity of the fathers
upon the children unto the third and
fourth generation Martin does this not
contradict Deuteronomy 24:16 yeah it
seems that way it seems that way right
but can we say that Deuteronomy 24:16 is
a statement cast in stone yes all right
so you cannot visit the iniquity of the
fathers upon the children yeah all right
that's it but the Bible says here that
the VIS the iniquity is visited unto the
third and fourth
generation so we need to unpack this we
need to understand it right to do a must
be a study all right so let's give the
short
version God says that the iniquity
cannot be transferred from the one to
the other so in what sense is this
iniquity transferred from generation to
generation
the answer is simple yeah the acts
that's and the example that the parents
present to their children is often
transferred to the children and they
enact what the parents
did and it takes up to the third and
fourth
generation now in the science of
epigenetics yeah they have discovered
that a bad habit mhm well it tradition
also falls under this yes a bad habit is
perpetuated at least until the third and
fourth generation in The Offspring that
which your parents ate you are inclined
to eat and your children are inclined to
eat and your grandchildren are inclined
to eat if you make a break and say I
don't want to do this you have a war
within yourself that's it so it's not
God visiting the iniquity it is the
iniquity being perpetuated for a few
Generations so these are all very
interesting things to study the iniquity
is um handed over through tradition and
epigenetics to the other correct but God
and that's why he's visiting is just
because of their choices correct did uh
Adam hand over his evil propensities to
his offspring yes yes and it takes a
battle to make yourself loose from that
you saw that in the first two sons
aha all right now here's another
interesting point Hebrews
7:9 even Levi who receives tithe paid
tithes through Abraham so to
speak for he was still in the loins of
his father when malisic met
him so if we unpack that Martin Levi
came 350 to to 400 years after Abraham
but since he was corporately in
Abraham he was still in the loins of
Abraham he in adverted commas paid tithe
in a corporate sense right all Humanity
was in Noah and Mrs Noah in a sense but
in Adam all Humanity male and female
were corporately present
literally so when Adam sin
all of humanity inherited his Fallen
nature not his sin no his Fallen
nature when Adam sinned all Humanity
inherited his Fallen nature with a
propensity to
sin who could then redeem the fall of
all humanity and corporately pay the
wages of sin which is death only one in
whom all Humanity was corporately
present before Adam existed
mhm and that is Christ through whom all
things were created and in whom dwelt
the fullness of the godhead bodily Jesus
said to them in John
8:58 most assuredly I say to you before
Abraham was I am mhm so here is The
Great I Am All Humanity was in Adam yeah
Adam fell and all Humanity inherited his
Fallen nature before Adam fell
corporately in whom was he Christ in
Christ so the only one who could bear
the iniquity of all humanity is someone
in whom Humanity was corporately present
before they existed and who did not sin
and who did not sin so that is Christ
because that's why Adam couldn't die for
the human race that's right so let's
unpack this even more Romans
9:29 and as zaiah said before except the
Lord Sabbat had left us a seed we had
been as Sodom and been made like
Gomorrah without the seed Humanity has
no hope right so Sodom and Gomorrah are
symbols of the final destruction thus
signifying the second death would you
agree with that
y but the word seed there is singular
Luke 811 now the parable is this the
seed is the word of God and the word of
God of course is Jesus in the beginning
was the word and the Word was with God
and the Word was
God Galatians 3:16 now to Abraham and
his seed were the promises made he does
not say unto seeds
plural as of many but as of one and to
your seed who is Christ
so the seed is the only one who can save
us yeah otherwise we'd be like Sodom and
Gomorrah that's
it Colossians 1:16 for by him were all
things created that are in heaven and
that are in Earth visible and invisible
whether they be Thrones or dominions or
principalities or powers or all things
were created by Him and for him he's the
Creator everything was corporately in
him before it existed yes does that
include the Angels yes okay he created
everything everything John 1:3 all
things were made by him all is a very
big word Martin yeah it's everything
there's nothing in the universe it says
there whether in heaven or on Earth and
without him was not anything made that
was made so he's the only
one so if you go to
Revelation where nobody was found worthy
to open the
scroll only the lamb that was slain was
worthy there was nobody else not in
Heaven Nor in the earth nor under the
Earth nowhere was there anybody but
him 2 Corinthians 5:21 and he has made
him to be sin for us who knew no sin
that he might be made the righteousness
of God in him so imagine this now Martin
this is be the study of the
ages here
is the god
man he is totally
sinless and he takes upon him the Fallen
flesh of
Adam but he is sinless yeah he has the
sinless a attribute from his father and
the Fallen attribute from his mother
M that sounds terrible but that's the
way it is
yeah and in that sense he being the
Creator God corporately has all of
humanity in
him okay let's
continue here's a quote from the review
in Herald by his obedience to all the
Commandments of God Christ wrought out a
Redemption for man this was not done by
going out of himself to another but by
taking Humanity into
himself thus Christ gave to humanity an
existence out of
himself to bring Humanity into Christ to
bring the Fallen race into Oneness with
divinity is the work of
redemption Christ took human nature that
men might be one with him as he is one
with the father that God may love man as
he loves his only begotten son that men
may be partakers of the divine nature
and be complete in him only God that's
it could do that yeah so does that make
Jesus God yes 100% 100% if he is not God
then Humanity cannot corporately be in
him that's true so the only one who can
pay the price is one who corporately can
die for and actually as all Humanity
that's it now M that thought of no it's
incomprehensible
incomprehensible every single sin that
every human being in the entire
existence of this world has ever
committed he bore yeah it crushed the
life out of him right it made the blood
come through his
skin in assuming Humanity Christ took
the part of every human
being he was the head of humanity a
being Divine and human with his long
human arm he could encircle Humanity
while with his Divine arm he could lay
hold of the Throne of the
infinite the only the only individual in
the entire universe who could die for
and as you and me was God himself that's
it Jesus Christ God manifest In the
Flesh because we were corporately in him
correct the Lord can take every one of
us into his Embrace for his arm
encircles the race let us remember this
after Christ had taken the necessary
step in Repentance conversion and faith
in behalf of the human race he went to
John to be baptized of him in Jordan
just stop
there did he ever sin no so did he ever
have to repent no no amazing he never
had to repent because he never had a sin
right did he ever have to be converted
no no because he was never unconverted
he was never unconverted and what did he
had to convert to to himself if so all
right did he have to
exercise this
Faith no he didn't have to because he
was perfect he was the essence he was
the the what faith is based on all right
so after Christ had taken the necessary
steps in
Repentance
conversion and faith in behalf of the
human race so if he didn't do it for
himself would he do it it for for us all
right how perfect would his repentance
have been in your behalf complete how
perfect the conversion how perfect the
faith yeah it wasn't the mustard seed
right no no then he went to John to be
baptized of him in the Jordan did he
need baptism no he didn't have to be
reborn right so he also did that on
behalf no wonder John forbade him yeah
saying I have need to be baptized of
thee and thou comest to me Jesus
answered suffered it to be so now for
thus it becometh us to fulfill all
righteousness who was he baptized for
for Humanity for the for Humanity for
the
transgressor is that the perfect baptism
yes is that the perfect
conversion and the Plan of
Salvation necessitates this yes
absolutely because if you don't have a
perfect salvation then you suffer the
wages of sin that's it so when he came
up out of the water he knelt down on the
banks of the Jordan and offered a prayer
such as had never been before entered
Heaven while he was praying the heavens
opened and the glory of God in the form
of a dove of burnished gold rested upon
him and from the highest Heaven Was
Heard the voice of the infinite one this
is my beloved Son in whom I am well
pleased
Martin is the Plan of Salvation laid
deep is there any other way let's ask
that question to satisfy the claims of
Justice no is there any other way to
satisfy the claims of mercy no not even
your repentance is good enough so is the
death of Christ an essentiality 100%
because even he had to repent on your
behalf and your you have to have faith
in that but Islam says it's a concocted
human philosophy and you've got goodness
in your this is very very fascinating is
it an important subject oh it's a
salvational subject all right Desire of
Ages paid 112 the savior's glance seems
to penetrate Heaven as he pours out his
soul in prayer well he knows how sin is
Harden the hearts of men and how
difficult it will be for them to discern
his mission and accept the gift of
Salvation is it still difficult for
Humanity today definitely I was are they
fighting against
it he pleads with the father for power
to overcome their unbelief to break the
fets with which Satan has enthralled
them and in their
behalf to conquer the Destroyer he asks
for the witness that God accepts
Humanity in the person of his
son only in his person was it possible
because only in him was Humanity
corporately prison
yeah never before had the Angels
listened to such a
prayer they are eager to Bear to their
loved Commander a message of assurance
and comfort but no the father himself
will answer the petition of his son
direct from the throne issues the beam
of his glory the heavens are opened upon
the savior's head descends a dove likee
form of purest light fit emblem of him
the meek and love holy one isn't that
magnificent it is truly amazing so Mar
in Hebrews 2:16 for verily he took not
on him the nature of
angels but he took on him the Seed of
Abraham now the new translations totally
violate this
verse because the new translations like
the NIV for example will read for verily
it is not angs he
helps there goes the entire Plan of
Salvation by destroying the beauty of
this verse in any case it would be a lie
yeah because because God certainly
helped Gabriel when he was held up by
the devil yeah on his way to talk to
Daniel right yes so it wouldn't even be
true it would be a lie but let's leave
it there because we've spoken about that
in previous Le
Romans 8:2 for the law of the spirit of
life in Christ Jesus has made me free
from the law of sin and death is he The
Mercy Seat yes is he the hilasterion
exactly is he the propitiation
yeah for what the law could not do and
that it was weak through the flesh God
sending his own son in the likeness of
sinful flesh and for sin condemned sin
in the flesh he paid the price mhm now
why could he be resurrected because
there was no sin he had no sin yeah so
death could not hold him because the
wages of sin is death he had no sin but
when he rose mhm didn't he rise
corporately with the whole of humanity
yes because everybody that he died for
through your faith in that blood that
was shed can also then rise with him all
right but here are two classes behind me
Martin the thief on the right and the
thief on the left
and they have to make a decision a
decision a choice did the other one mock
yes he mocked right both of them mocked
both of them mocked in the in the
beginning but then he contemplated
Christ and he decided that this was the
way to Salvation and the other one
rejected it yeah two classes so even the
Risen
Savior cannot save the impenitent no
because you cannot pay the price for the
impenitent so there's no salvation in
sin there's only salvation from from sin
that's very important because a lot of
people once you mentioned it earlier so
once you repent and you acknowledge this
now you want to live as you please
before it cannot work no cannot work
must be a conversion so verse four says
that the righteousness of the law might
be fulfilled in us who walk not after
the flesh but after the spirit so is the
law righteous oh yes it's righteous of
course it's righteous because and it
stands and it stands not gone so it
doesn't do away with the law it
establishes the
law all right let's contemplate this
this is again one of my thoughts here
when God breathed the breath of life
into man that life was
eternal conditional to obedience
yeah is that right true the same
condition applies today because God does
not change so the only way to get it
back is if the lifegiver gives it back
and that is only possible in Christ
because he's the Creator yeah so Martin
religions that reject Christ are they
outside the Plan of Salvation yes is it
important that we tell them that it is
it or shall we embrace them and say
you're beautiful with without Christ no
unfortunately you have to pluck him out
of the fire and how much worse for those
that claim to be Christians but deny the
atonement isn't that even worse that is
because that's actually a slap in
Jesus's face telling him we don't need
you
yes Acts
17:25 neither is worshiped with men's
hands as though he needed anything
seeing he giveth to all life and breath
and all all things so where does your
life come from from Christ from the
lifegiver or Romans 6:3 know ye not that
so many of us as were baptized into
Jesus Christ were baptized into his
death all right so if you were baptized
into his death did you then die in
Christ
yes but Martin if you died in Christ
then you paid the penalty of
sin he did it on your behalf
therefore we are buried with him in
baptism into death that like as Christ
was raised up from the dead by the glory
of the father even so we also shall walk
in nness of life so if you are raised up
with him yeah then you must be like him
exactly because he there must be a
change you cannot walk as you used to so
verse 5 says for for if we have been
planted together in the likeness of his
death we shall be also in the likeness
of his resurrection that's the Plan of
Salvation is it deep oh
it's thank God he did it is there any
other way no unfort you cannot have it
any other way without negating
Justice that everything else is
selfishness and thinking of your own way
all right unpack it even further Romans
3:25 whom God has set forth to be a
propitiation a
mercy through faith in his blood to
declare his righteousness for the
remission of sins that are passed
through the forbearance of God how am I
saved through Christ through his
righteousness there's no other way my
good works won't cut it Martin does that
mean I mustn't have good works no like
we've mentioned numerous times it must
be an outflow of the salvation that you
find in Christ so to declare I say at
this time his
righteousness that he may be just and
the justifier of him which believeth in
Jesus so will it help me to wear a
scapula
no no no no nothing so where is boasting
then it is excluded by what law of Works
nay but by the law of Faith therefore we
conclude that a man is justified by by
faith without the Deeds of the law your
Works won't help you no but it's
important to have the works if you have
the faith correct 2 Corinthians 5:14 For
the Love of Christ constrain us because
we thus judge that if one died for all
then were all dead mhm justice has been
served served the transgression of the
law has got its
penalty it's such a deep plan if it's so
incredibly
amazing so Mar knowing this Romans
6:6 that our old man is crucified with
him that the body of sin might be
destroyed and henceforth we should not
serve
sin so you may no longer transgress the
law because sin is the transgression of
the
law for he that is dead is freed from
sin now if we be dead with Christ we
believe that we shall also live with him
M knowing that Christ being raised from
the dead dieth no more Mar is there any
Eucharistic sacrifice there no no weekly
thing
nothing death has no more dominion over
him for in that he died he died unto sin
once but in that he liveth he lives unto
God likewise reckon yourselves also to
be dead dead indeed unto sin but alive
unto God through Jesus Christ Our Lord
Martin this
reconciliation this bringing mankind
back into harmony with the will of God
is the essence of what happened here and
it it's such a beautiful thing to to
realize this why would God then like
certain people say okay he's freed me
from the law why do you want to say that
so that you do what you you're not
supposed to makes no sense there's no
sense in that why would God want you to
take away the law if it is there to help
you correct so let's read this statement
here from selected messages when you
turn away from the broken system that
can hold no water and in the name of
Jesus your Advocate come directly to God
asking for the things you need the
righteousness of Christ will be revealed
as your
righteousness the virtue of Christ as
your virtue you will then understand
that justification will come alone
through faith in Christ for in Jesus is
revealed the Perfection of the character
of God in his life is manifested the
outworking of the principles of
Holiness through the atoning blood of
Christ The Sinner is set free from the
bondage and condemnation nothing that
gets rid of every religious system other
than biblical Christianity that's it
because everybody else uses their Works
to try and attain that so should we
inform Muslims that this is what they
need yeah don't let them be shall we
inform Buddhists everybody Hindus so
it's such an important statement that
we've just made said because you must
love them but that love must manifest in
preaching to them to get out of there
yes this curriculum of the ages they
need to understand it because if you
don't understand it you will be on the
on the side of
Cain it is through the atoning blood of
Christ that the sinner is set free from
the bondage and condemnation through the
Perfection of the sinless substitute and
shity he may run in the race of humble
obedience to All God's Commandments
without Christ is under the condemnation
of the law there's no mercy seat you've
gotten rid of him he's the
hilasterion always a sinner but through
faith in Christ he's made just before
God this is the Plan of Salvation it is
deep it required the ultimate
sacrifice Isaiah
45:17 but Israel shall be saved in the
Lord with an everlasting self salvation
ye shall not be ashamed nor confounded
Without
End surely says Isaiah
45:4 surely shall one say in the Lord
have I righteousness and strength is
there any conflict between the Old
Testament and the new
no even to him shall men come and all
that are incensed against him shall be
ashamed are there many that are incensed
against him yeah do they call it vile
Doctrine
yes verse 25 in the Lord shall all the
seed of Israel be justified and shall
Glory I would like to point out that we
should note the present
tense but also note that the present
tense is
conditional if if
if so let's have a look at a couple of
these verses and how they've been
changed in some of the new
translations for we are saved by
hope what's the thief on the cross there
Martin being saved or was he saved he
was saved all right this this salvation
is conditional to obedience that's it
doesn't get rid of the condition but if
you're Justified you're Justified that's
it then you should stay from there on in
that and that's a sanctification all
right for we are saved by hope but hope
that he seen is not hope for what a man
seeth why does he yet hope for so it has
to be by
faith now if you take the NIV then it
says for in this hope we were saved Past
St but hope that he seen when the rest
is the same well let's take Corinthians
1:18 for the preaching of the Cross is
to them that perish foolishness but unto
us which are saved it is the power of
God what what did the thief on the cross
have salvation he was saved right yeah
it's the power of God let's read NIV for
the message of the Cross is foolishness
to those who are perishing but to us who
are being
saved it is the power of God Is there is
there an inconsistency here for sure
that is telling you that it's a constant
thing that has to happen now I'm not
saying that I can say oh I'm saved no if
I don't fulfill the conditions then I'm
a liar that's it right 1 Corinthians
15:2 by which also you are saved if you
keep in memory what I preached unto you
can see the conditional portion
condition you are saved if you keep in
memory what I preached unto you unless
you have believed in vain note that the
new translations use the past tense and
make salvation a process rather than a
completed work yeah would you agree with
that I agree with that is it problematic
to you very because the problem is that
people it comes almost back to works I
have to work then towards my salvation
it's Catholic
theology 2 Corinthians 2:15 for we are
unto God a sweet Savor of Christ into
them that are saved in them that
perish if you read it in the NIV being
saved if you take Philippians 1:28 and
in nothing terrified by your adversaries
which is to them an evident token of
petion but to you of
Salvation if you take the same verse in
the NIV it says but that you will be
saved future tense future T there's
something wrong here yeah if you are
good you you you'll be saved so can I
say that the saved in Christ are th not
dead but alive in him if he liveth they
live they are all credited with having
paid the price in for if you are in
Christ your but you have to appropriate
it that's it and then out of
automatically you will have to live your
life then as he will correct help you
through that so let's see what this
quote says in the Desire of Ages Christ
declared to his hearers that if there
were no resurrection of the Dead the
scriptures which they profess to believe
would be of no
avail he said but as touching the
resurrection of the Dead have you not
read that which was spoken unto you by
God saying I am the god of Abraham and
the god of Isaac and the god of Jacob
and he's not the God God is not the god
of the dead but of the living now listen
to this Martin God counts the things
that are not as though they were he sees
the end from the beginning and beholds
the result of his work as though it were
now a
lished so the thief on the cross was it
now accomplished yes right there the
precious dead from Adam down to the last
Saint who dies will hear the voice of
the Son of God and will come forth from
the grave to Immortal
Life God will be their God and they
shall be his people there will be a
close and tender relationship between
God and His risen sense this condition
which is anticipated in his purpose he
beholds as it were already existing the
Dead live in him so is the King James
correct yes 100% it's a a a present
tense not a future or past T and if you
take the woman at the well the same
happened there it was present God said
yes year ago and then he said go and sin
no more yes so it was justification and
then he said to her so stay in the
justification and live a Sanctified life
yes Galatians 2:20 let's read it again I
am crucified with Christ nevertheless I
live yet not I but Christ liveth in me
now if Christ liveth in me do I not act
and strive to be like
him and the life which I now live in the
flesh I live by faith of the Son of God
who loved me and gave himself for me I
live by faith of the Son of God how he
lived his faith I must
exercise so can we say that Christ in
you is sanctification and sanctification
is surrender of self to Christ yeah so
that he can work in you yes true
sanctification does not just change the
actions it changes the motive it cannot
spring from a carnal heart if you want
to keep the law just to be saved that
will be a problem so if you're actually
keeping the law who's keeping it for you
in you Christ so where can you boast of
your good works nowhere nothing
nothing so nevertheless I live yet not I
but Christ liveth in me as we have
seen so it can never be by our work only
by his would you agree with that yeah
100% so what is my contribution nothing
nothing
does this mean I have nothing to do oh
no no I must die to self but life in
abundance comes from him who created us
for his glory would you agree with that
yeah death cannot resurrect me only the
lifegiver can and only he can restore
the image of God in man so true
sanctification cannot boast would you
agree
100% all right let's corroborate that
from a statement with in steps to Christ
the closer we come to Jesus the more
fals we will see in our own lives y we
will see our faults more clearly as we
compare our
sinless as we compare our sinful selves
with the perfect
savior this will show that Satan's false
ideas are losing their power over us and
that the lifegiving spirit of God is
leading us you I had this young girl
come to me and say I'm so
convicted of my
sinfulness does that mean that God has
now rejected me yeah because they think
I must be sinless already and I said the
exact opposite of what you are saying
the fact that you are aware of your
sinfulness means that God is speaking to
your heart exactly and you can ask him
to help you to emulate his righteousness
because it's Satan that Whispers in your
ear that you don't have to worry about
this correct so if that voice of
conscience is quieted then you have to
worry then you have to worry and if you
think they are
perfect then you have to really
worry John 19:5 then came Jesus forth
wearing the crown of thorns and the
purple robe and pilate said unto them
behold the
man it is not fear of punishment or the
hope of everlasting reward that lead
leads the Disciples of Christ to follow
him they behold the savior's matchless
love revealed throughout his pilgrimage
on Earth from the manger of Bethlehem to
calvary's cross and the sight of him
attracts it softens and subdues the Soul
love awakens in the heart of the
beholders they hear his voice and they
follow him now M when you were living in
transgression and people said to you the
WTH of God shall fall upon you and
obliterate you did it scare the heck out
of you no sometimes I must say that the
fearfulness or or the stories of burning
hell that you didn't feel very
comfortable with that but that wasn't a
hard change to because a change out of
fear will never be consistent yes it
just made me more rebellious yeah so
what actually is it that draws you when
I am lifted up I will draw all men to me
so do we have to contemplate this Plan
of Salvation daily
daily Micah
6:8 he has showed thee oh man what is
good and what does the Lord require of
thee but to do justly and to love mercy
and to walk humbly with thy God that's
it it's a very simple recipe
now Martin that basically concludes our
discussion The Plan of Salvation is it
laid deep yes is there any other way no
you cannot satisfy Justice and mercy any
other way there was no other way if
there were another way the god of the
universe surely would have found it
right true then he would have presented
it to everybody that needs that at this
stage has to go through the Salvation
process so basically Martin with our
previous verse we can conclude the
matter but I thought you know maybe we
should read together Psalms
103 and everybody can contemplate it for
themselves we're not going to discuss it
but just to show the character of God
yeah so it's the psalm of David bless
the Lord of my soul and all that is
within me blesses His holy name bless
the Lord oh my soul and forget not all
his benefits who forgiveth all thine
iniquities who Health all thy
diseases does he have the right to do it
yes amen he's the Healer who redeemeth
thy life from destruction who crowneth
thee with loving kindness and Tender
Mercies who satisfies thy mouth with
good things so that thy youth is renewed
like the Eagles the Lord executeth
righteousness and judgment did we
discuss these things MH for all that are
oppressed he made known his way unto
Moses his acts unto the children of
Israel the Lord is merciful and gracious
slow to anger and plenteous in Mercy do
we have Justice and mercy the whole time
balance
there he will not always CH neither will
he keep his anger for
forever is this world of sin coming to
an end at some stage yes and that anger
is not directed towards the sinner it's
towards the sin
correct he has not dealt with us after
our sins nor rewarded us according to
our iniquities is that right
no for as the heaven is high above the
Earth so great is his Mercy towards them
that fear him as far as the East is from
the West so far has he removed our
transgression from us how complete is
the Plan of Salvation full absolutely
Immaculate you will one day stand before
God as though you have never sinned
because the record of sin will have been
removed like as a father pth his
children so the Lord pth them that fear
Him for he knoweth our frame he
rememberthe therefore condescend to pay
this enormous price yeah can you imagine
that price Martin
dying for every sin that has ever been
committed feeling it in its intensity
the pain that goes along with it plus
the
consequences and not even have any part
in it no so he did it totally out of
love as for man his days are like grass
as the flower of the field so he
flourishes for the wind passes over it
is gone and the place thereof shall know
it no more
but the mercy of the Lord is from
Everlasting to Everlasting upon them
that fear him and his righteousness unto
the children's
children isn't that a nice contrast to
what we've seen yeah like we've seen on
the epigenetics part to such as keep his
Covenant and to those that remember his
Commandments to do
them is obedience essential the Lord has
prepared his throne in the heavens and
his kingdom ru ruleth over all does he
have a law yeah bless the Lord ye angels
that excel in strength that do his
Commandments hearkening unto the voice
of his word as in heaven so on so on
Earth bless ye the Lord all ye his hosts
ye Ministers of his that do his pleasure
bless the Lord all his Works in all
places of his Dominion bless the Lord oh
my son is that a beautiful song I think
that is a
heartfelt acknowledgement of what God
did for us through the Plan of Salvation
reconciling a Fallen
World in himself amazing and that's why
it's important to contemplate this spare
a thoughtful hour every day
contemplating what Christ has done for
us on the cross yes let's
pray heavenly father thank you for the
plan of
Salvation thank you for the
atonement thank you for the
propitiation thank you for that Mercy
Seat without it all Humanity would be
loss and if I look at the religious
systems of the
world and the philosophies of the
atheists Lord I
shudder because they look past this
great great event the greatest event
that has ever taken place in the
universe that will be our contemplation
our curriculum our study through all
eternity because we comprehend a
fraction of its depth because as high as
the heavens are above us so high so much
higher are the thoughts of God thank you
for giving us a
glimpse help us Lord to reach Humanity
that they might see in that
cross the way to Salvation is my prayer
in Jesus name amen amen
[Music]